la fin de la phase allée d'un
championnat est souvent un tournant dans
une saison face au Paris la garder
Racing le challenge semblait compliqué à
relever pour le Badminton Club de
Montini mais les badur intin restaient
sur deux victoires consécutives après un
départ manqué et deux défaites face au
poils lourd du championnat des succès
qui ont permis à l'équipe cinquantinoise
de s'unir dans la difficulté la dernière
journée s'est bien passée on a réussi à
gagner des
matchs qui ont fait se souder l'équipe
je trouve et c'était plutôt positif sur
la fin de la sur la dernière journée là
c'était on sentait vraiment une bonne
ambiance entre les joueurs dans l'équipe
on reste confiant si on arrive à faire
une deuxième partie comme la première ce
sera ça sera très bien pour nous sur le
papier les joueurs inimontin ont moins
d'expérience et sont moins bien classés
que ceux des équipes leaders comme le
Racing ou l'ilbon tous de première série
l'objectif de départ était de figurer
parmi les quatre premiers de la poule ce
qui assure le maintien dans la division
pour l'instant Montini 4e accroche le
bon vagon le bilan est plutôt positif
puisquon a deux défaites et de
pour l'instant on est 4e du classement
donc on se maintient donc c'est
l'objectif est pour l'instant réalisé
malgré toute sa Grint l'équipe de
Philippe Gomez s'est incliné face au
Racing et plutôt sèchement
match